she knew this one no Debbie ocean  convicted felon her brother Danny ocean  more convicted felon she was present on  the night of the incident oh so oh you  want to hit a jewelry store  not exactly a diamond mine yes exactly  right before what the met three to half  weeks and that would be hosting its  annual ball and we are going to rob it  sixteen point five million dollars in  each of your bank accounts five weeks  from now that's a lot they've got every  inch of this place covered this is most  sophisticated security in the world  how long did it take you to figure all  this out five years eight months and 12  days why do you need to do this because  that's what I'm gonna okay everybody  let's get started here we go count me  down three two  came on  she said  dear God that was exact you  Silvio cos we prepare for this  [Music]  we will not be the prime suspects  wait-wait-wait-wait-wait every time you  do they have to start from surprise wait  what'd you do I turn it on  you